la députée LFI rachel kké a de nouveau
faire parler d'elle oui déjà lors de son
élection euh bon ça avait suscité
l'attention des médias euh voilà alors
moi je l'aimais bien en plus ouais moi
auss on l'aime bienou ou voilà mais là
on a un problème quand même non même si
on l'aime bien elle vit toujours dans un
HLM malgré son salaire de député oui ou
alors euh et Jean-Luc Mélenchon lui il
dit qu'il faut qu'elle reste dans son
H&M j'chon ton ami c'est pas mon ami
mais t ami sont pas mes amis si si donc
Rachel keké on va vous faire un petit
rappel de l'histoire j'aimais bien
savoir ce qu'en pense C téléspectateurs
donc cette député comment elle elle
touche en tant que député alors elle
touche exactement
9277 brut si on prend les trois
indemnitésou plus est dans un H&M de
fond plus 5373 d'avance de Freis manda
d'accord ok bon ben on va voir regardez
le le rappel de l'histoire j'ai hâte
d'avoir la vie de de Géraldine surtout
et moins celui de Gill verd je suis
d'accord avec G je c ah ouais alors j'ai
pas d'avoir ton avis d'accord avec G ver
dans son cas elle précisément je trouve
qu'elle a été irréprochable oui si c'est
un cas très particulier elle a prévenu
son prévenu
bienant
demand ancienne femme de ménage Rachel k
se fait connaître en 2019 lors d'une
intense greffe des techniciennes de
surface je me sens comment je peux dire
fier la tête haute j'aime ma dignité en
2022 investi par la inoumise Rachel kké
devient député qui a déjà touché 800 €
900 € par mois personne vous savez pas
ce que c'est et mercredi dernier le
média factuel a fait une révélation la
femme habite toujours dans son HLM de 80
m² malgré un revenu très confortable de
député de 7600 €. défendu par Jean-Luc
Mélenchon rachel kké a affirmé payer un
surloyer et compte bien rester dans son
logement elle ne compte pas faire
carrière en politique et ne sera pas élu
toute sa vie c'est pour cela qu'elle a
choisi de rester de vivre dans son
appartement
mais cette annonce surprend aujourd'hui
certains Français qui estiment qu'elle
devrait laisser sa place à d'autres
alors un an après son élection Rachel
keké vit dans un HLM malgré son salaire
de député êtes-vous
choqué alors êtes-vous choqué non non
non non non ah Pascal oui ah d'abord je
vais vous savez quoi je vais laisser la
parole à Gill Verdes d'abord allez c'est
rare je suis pas du tout choqué euh vous
voulez qu'elle vive où elle ne sera pas
éternellement députée elle habite là il
y a quatre enfants elle habite là depuis
des années c'est pas une professionnelle
de la politique elle paye un surloyer le
bailleur c'est parfaitement légal le
bailleur social a dit ok si elle paye un
surloyer ce qu'elle fait combi je ne
sais pas on n'a pas la somme du chloyer
on n' pas la somme du chloyer je je ne
l'ai pas donc c'est vrai que les
indemnités si on les cumule d'un député
c'est énorme mais moi je pense que dans
quelques années elle retournera à la vie
civile elle a été connue pour sa lutte
quelques an il y a plein de gens qui
vont peut-être trouver du travail dans
quelques années oui mais moi je suis pas
choqué parce que si on l' de là elle va
vivre où et dans quelques années ave
avec ce qu'elle prend elle va trouver
pas trouver quelqu'un qui lu foelle sera
plus
déput il faudrait justement lui dire que
une fois qu'elle sera plus député elle
pourra peut-être inégrer mais après si
elle prend 9000 € par
[Musique]
mois je te reconnais pas GT je te
reconnais justement la connerie à son
parox pour moi c'est pour moi c'est
scandaleux la morale doit primer en
politique quelle que soit la couleur
quelle que soit la position que tu as
que tu as eu et que tu auras à l'avenir
sinon alors il y a tout le monde a une
bonne excuse moi je je je excuse-moi
mais je je parlais de moi j'ai j'ai eu
un appartement social à la RIVP pendant
7 ans j'ai été nommé à Londres la RIVP
c'est la régie immobiliaère de la ville
de
Paris lorsque j'ai eu l'appartement je
rentrais parfaitement dans les clous 7
ans après je rentrais plus dans les
clous et surtout j'ai été nommé à
Londres j'allais avoir un surplu de
salaire j'ai rendu les clés de mon
appartement tu avais combien d'enfants
j'avais deux enfants je les ai toujours
j'ai j'ai j'ai j'ai j'ai appelé la
mairie et j'ai dit je rends mon
appartement parce que ça me choquait
moralement de pouvoir être correspondant
de gagner quelque chose qui est
comparable à ce qu'elle ce qu'elle
touche aujourd'hui et je suis désolé
mais non c'est quand tu as quitté la
RIVP ouais
j'ai ou c'est le nom de la ré imobère de
la V ta situation professionnelle est
pas la même que celle non mais c'est pas
la même situation
professionn il y a plein de gens qui
disent moi j'ai 700 € par mois et j'ai
pas droit à unm comment ça y a plein des
familles qui ont 4 enfants qui se
retrouvent dans des situations comme ça
elle elle doit montrer l'exemple je suis
désolé quand on représente dans quelques
secondes je vais lâcher Ron euh
oui il est colèreire elle doit elle doit
monter l'exemple mais non mais combien
de femmes PASC combien de femmes ont
quatre enfants en France cherchent un
logement HLM et non pas les revenus de
Madame combien
question juste Rachel k serait de droite
il serait pour ou contre qu'elle garde
son logement il serait contre pour on
pourrait discuter voilà
merci la clarté puisque ça le mérite de
la clarté g puisque tu as dit tout à
l'heure elle est femme de ménage et elle
a qure enfants ce qui veut dire que bah
oui mais ce qui veut dire que pour toi
sa position sociale d'avant et d'après a
un impact sur le fait de savoir si elle
doit avoir un logement social VI vous
savez qui s Rachel k elle a galéré toute
sa vie elle
ex ronne après quoi qu'il
arrive ça ça serait bien on lui garantit
qu'elle le retrouvera après ça oui mais
pour l'instant à 9000 boules par mois je
suis désolé mon ch là sur les Réau son
pe quand même comprendre la dame qui a
peur pour l'avenir pour ses enfants
aussi si on lui dit on lui garantit
qu'ou après moi je pense que ça c'est
bien je écoutez làdessus parce que alors
moi je trouve que c'est j'ai pas envie
d'accabler cette femme en fait fait
parce que je trouve que son parcours il
est juste incroyable il est admirable
elle est tellement singulière que je
trouve que évidemment on peut trouver ça
un peu choquant et évidemment on se
dirait ouais peut-être qu'elle aurait dû
partir et tout ça mais à partir du
moment où elle a tout bien fait elle a
prévenu son bailleur elle a elle a donné
un surloyer elle a plutôt été exemplaire
elle a quatre enfants qu'elle a élevé
seule dans cette h bien sûr qu'elle est
pas la seule femme de de France à avoir
quatre enfants seuls bien sûr que toi
Jacques tu as été exemplaire et et tu as
quitté ton HM voilà et bravo et je t'en
félicite dans son caselle elle est prê s
administrer elle habitude elle a
toujours elle a toujours vécu ici quel
âge on connaî pas quel âge ont ses
enfants peut-être que pour elle c'est
important de rester là je trouve que
c'est pas un immense scandale il y a
tellement des immenses Scand elle a
accédé à un rang qui fait queelle sera
toujours entourée et elle aura une
famille politique qui l'aidera quoi
arrête la France ins la France ins est
en train d'exploser en plein vol ça
existera peut-être pas dans 4 ans et
dans 4 ans elle il va falloir qu'elle
remette en jeu son mandat et après dans
ce cas-là je peux dire aussi Louis
Boyard il a un fort
ça
ch tu vois après tu dis voilà quoi bon
ils sont bons dans l'immobilier ils sont
bons dans l'immobilier en rev je suis
pas du tout d'accord avec Gill quand il
dit c'est une femme elle est noire elle
a subi du racisme non pas du tout c'est
pas du pas dit qu'elle était noire si tu
as dit elle a subi du racisme pourquoi
elle a subi du racisme parce qu'elle est
[Rires]
noire donc non craquant je ne veux pas
la victimisation ça ça ne plaît pas
l'essentialisation ça plaî pas c'est
tout ce que dé test du côté de tes amis
justement mais dans son k précisément
dans ce cas particulier j'aimerais bien
qu'on voilà c'est au cas par cas
j'aimera bien qu'on ait le montant du
surloyer par cas pas de marque pas par
pardon on embrasse également terre de
fenêtre merci oui moi le montant du
surloyer il m'intéresse pas je prends
juste les faits et je me dis que c'est
quelquun qui va mais c'est pas
3500500 quand tu prends 7 8000 €
Paris
[Applaudissements]
quand tu prends quand tu prends 6 7000 €
par mois tu peux pas tu peux pas dire je
vais aller je vais habiter dans un HLM
il faut laisser la place là où il a
raison Cyril c'est qu'il dit il faudrait
lui garantir après de retrouver un HLM
parce qu'elle a dit elle a dit qu' avec
ses quatre enfants elle voulait pas
aller changer d'école elle voulait
rester dans le cadre elle voulait rester
là où il habite là je la suis il y a pas
de problème sauf que on sait très bien
ce qui fait ça c'est qu'il a de des fois
deux 3 ans d'attente de liste d'attente
pour avoir un HLM donc si elle se barre
de son HLM elle est pas sûre d'en
récupérer un et moi je vais plus loin
pourquoi elle elle serait en priorité
pour récupérer un HLM et pourquoi il y a
des familles qui attendent et qui
galèent 2 3 ans à qui on laisse sur le
carreau et qui touche 7 800 balles et
elle elle a 9000 balles elle pas
heement message que je reçois ma sœur
seu C enfants dans 45 m² n'a toujours
pas de logement social et on lui a coupé
les aides voilà qu'elle laisse sa place
à des gens qui sont vraiment dans le
besoin tu combien d'enfants dorment dans
la rue en France et dans dans une
voitureon il y a plus que
ça non
mais je sués
meut faut qu sil plît sil plaît faut qu'
le quit qu'elle le donne à quelqu'un qui
en a vraiment besoin aujourd'hui à
l'instantti et après si elle est
vraiment en difficulté on lui garantit
qu'elle retrouvera son hlm mais là les
gars je suis désolé Jean-Luc Mélenchon a
dit qu'est-ce qu'il a dit
encore mais j'aimerais bien savoir sa
citation parce que c'est toujours
intéressant oui qui voulait parler non
mais donc il faut qu'elle reste pour une
question de morale parce qu'on est
d'accord qu'elle est pas hors la loi
elle est
pas une question de morale quel part
pour une question de morale tiens
nouvelle polémique des fachot alors à
chaque fois qu'il y a une polémique
Mélenchon c'est des fach ou racistes
comme c'est toujours son truc mélchon
c'est des amis jein voilà à propos de
son lement je souhaite qu'elle y reste
alors lui il souhaite qu'elle y reste
donci lui c'est lui c'est c'est c'est
transac il décide toi tu es un truc
c'est un fou trans bon quit à ce que son
loyer soit adapté elle n'est pas élue à
vie c'est une bonne chose que les élus
du peuple n'abandonnent pas la vie des
l'UR bon non je suis pas d'accord avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon elle doit quitter son
HLM et revenir après que je pense après
c'est peut-être pas moi qui qui qui
est c'est sa défense elle a demandé à
rester à l'endroit où elle a été élue et
donc qu'elle connait bien et elle a sa
vie où ses enfants à mon avis il y a des
trucs très sympas he là-bas elle peut
trouver un truc un peu
plus
chev elle elle peut trouver un truc et
qu'elle l'URA dans le privé C dans privé
trouver dans le privé il y a combien de
locataires elle a les garanties elle a
tout pointer devant un propriétaire avec
000 balles par mois il va dire bien sûr
que je teou le truc revenir après exuse
elle le dit dans son communiqué pr que
elle ne conçoit pas son rôle d'élu comme
une carrière donc ça veut
direure 21
ça
c'est la politique c'est l'exemplarité
exemplaire exemplaire elle dit tout elle
déclare
tout bien on aurait d lui dire dans ce
donc il faut lui envoyer des huissiers
pour lui
direout de justice hers des haricots
haric la France insoumise qui est un
parti exemplaire aurait dû lui dire on
veut de l'exemplarité donc tu dois
quitter ton
lètqucqu a raison 100% les mec
l'argument de je c'est c'est précaire et
je ne sais pas si je ferai de la
politique dans 10 ans mais les mecs qui
sait sil va rester à son poste dans 10
ans non mais nimpi il y a des gens qui
se font Rener tous les jours un mec un
mec qui vend des voitures ce qui sait si
va dans l'immobilier en ce moment il y a
tous les jours des gens qui se font
virer parce que ça bouge pas et
l'immobilier est dans une situation
catastrophique alors il va dire non mais
je suis dans l'immobilier moi donc je
vais dire peut-être que dans 2 mois jeis
perdre mon taf non mais il faut arrêter
en vérité elle a je le pense elle a
justement un poste qui est beaucoup plus
sûr que beaucoup de gens parce que au
moins elle sait qu' lui reste combien
d'années là
encore rendez compte 4 ans qui qui non
mais non mais je dire que vous êtes fous
qui aujourd'hui a un travail et il se
dit c'est sûr que je serai encore là
dans 4 ans et que je vais prendre mon
SAL que ce soit un chef d'entreprise ou
que ce soit un salarié personne ne peut
te le dire a calculé 4 ans 80000 x 4
80000 € voilà merci 320000 € voilà donc
après même si elle est plus député elle
peut même s'acheter une maison conse imm
conseill
immobili vérité 3 précarité c'est une
connerie arrêtez 1200 balles la retraite
après 1200 balles la retraite en plus
après VO quoi qu'il en soit très fort
sur les retraites lui même si fait un a
ça m'intéresse oui mais après on dit
aussi aussi que quand ils achètent un
truc ils habitent dans des pavillons ils
sont loin de leur administrés ils sont
horors sol ils connaissent pas la
réalité le quotidien de de ce dont il
parle ti il a un ami à moi un ami à moi
Mélenchon égal retraite à 9000 € par
mois s jamais d'avoir travaillé retraite
de parlementaire merci Stéphan c'est
vrai voilà donc alors non mais pas le
cas mais mais si donnit pas des leçons
on s'en fout à la limite mais ils sont
tout le temps en train de donner des
leçons lui il a donné 100 millions au
resto c'est pas assez lui il a fait ça
c'est pas assez lui donne pas assez
d'argent lui gagne trop d' donne pas et
toi tu
prends derère la semaine dernière ils
ont critiqué Bernard AR qui avait donné
10 millions d'Uros du cœur et derrière
dit non elle prend 9000 € par mois mais
elle doit garder son son logement social
non mais les mecs eu c'est non mais eux
ils osent tout voilà c'est c'est
voilàçonach est victime de Mélenchon et
son éta partout ailleurs
non ça passerait pas non plus ça
passerait pas non plus ça passerait en
vrai à 9000 € par mois tu gardes pas un
lchement social c'est tout et quand tu
sais que tu as 4 ans encore à faire je
suis désolé les mecs c'est un c'est
inaudible on peut pas entendre ça je
suis désolé qui peut se dire aujourd'hui
j'aurais mon taf dans 4 ans mais vous
êtes fous quoi personne personne même
vous et vous les premier d'ailleurs non
mais c'est vrai non mais voilà mais
c'est vrai donc arrêtez les gars elle s
sûr de toucher 9000 € par moi pendant 4
ans r c'est pas sûr s'il font une
dissolution pas sûr mais sin Mo tu dis
je prendre 3600 4 je pas grave jeog
je j'ai envie de te dire une décision
qu'elle aura d prendre avant quand elle
s'est engagé en politique quand elle s
engagé qu'elleit campagne parourette
femme fait qu'elle ne pvit pas prendre
cettecem de M
vie
parcours femes seul qui ont enant
aujour'hui son
s à elle d'avoir d'abord le log social
exactement même elle je pense qu'elle
devrait dire j'ai envie d'aider
quelqu'un je suis désolé moi j'ai eu la
chance de pour Mme faire un coup
politique exactement
voilà voilà l'intelligence voilà
qu'est-ce qu'il a mais un coup politique
c'est la démagogie elle
PASM t'arrêes au seul truc parce que lui
il a pas dit que c'est ce qu'il faut
faire c'est ce qui vient pas faire en
fait es plus con que ce que je
pensaisuse non mais je t'aime beaucoup
non mais vraiment
VI dire elle devrait
quitter voilà elle devit faire un
coupqueismeilà mais toi tu prends tout
au premier
degré qu'est-ce qu'elle va faire vous
dites elle devrait avoir un logement
social garanti après elle n'en aura
jamais
C gont comment les autes g 3600 comment
ils font pour trouver un logement ils
sont sur liste d'attente ils prennent
900 balles par mois et ils attendent que
la mairie les appelle
je vais dire la vérité moi elle va
prendre 1200 € après déjà je peux dire
elle peut mettre de l'argent de côté et
quose d's elle occupe un appartement que
des gens peut-être plus nécessitent qu'
a
besoin les chér on peut partir dans un
débat et dire on pense ça et vu les
arguments que j'ai avancé il a changé
d'AV bravo bravo
Bernard j'étais en train de ce n'est pas
être une jourouette c'est juste être
intelligent bravo Bernard c'est ça le
débat j'écoute les arguments des uns et
des autres et là ça changé un peu d'avis
oui un tout petit peu parce que quand
même ouais c'est vrai parce que moi je
tris tout ce qu'elle a fait est légal on
peut pas lui reprocher ça mais en
revanche elle occupe une place que
d'autres personnes plus méritantes les
mot qui sonne ouais vous êtes formidable
c'est ça raisonne dans ma tête voir
qu'on pens les téléspectateurs oui voilà
merci au revoir 75 % merci Gill verd tu
peux encore aller acheter de la des
yaourts là dehors et arrêter de nous
faire chier merci on va se retrouver
dans un instant les amours merci d'être
là tellement
heureux